哈喽大家好我是[来源标识已去除]欢迎大家来到[来源标识已去除]出品的拼多多成长训练营的第五节课程店铺权重分析这些课程的重点跟大家去讲解一下店铺和店铺之间的权重高低有哪些其实非常非常的简单
第一个店铺的类型分为品牌黑标店大于自由品牌店大于个人店那么店铺的级别里面来说时间店的权重大于专卖专营和个人店
相反这个地方如果非得去做区分的话 谁才是权重最牛逼最高的店铺那是品牌能上百亿补贴的旗舰店权重最高
那么权重区分完以后呢 流量有哪些区别
第一个黑标店铺由于满足特定的标准并通过系统严格的评估能够在平台上享受更高的曝光度和更好的流量分配
接下来的整个拼多多品质化和品牌化你们会有很大的一个感知拥有品牌旗舰店的这个店铺里面去上的链接再去做付费推广的同时天然有优势这是第一个
第二个非黑标店铺可能会受到各种原因的制约呀比如说店铺整体的表现商品的质量以及用户的等等的一个反馈从而影响你流量那个大小第三个黑标店铺和非黑标店铺不在一个流量池
你可以这么去进行理解因为黑标拥有定价权拥有很多的资源位的加持并且直动车不比价整体的产品不比价他就不在一个流量池里面去进行比大小所以黑标只针对黑标白牌针对全网所有的一个产品所以他们会有一个很明显的区别同时呢非黑标店铺及自由品牌店和个人店铺的流量同在一个流量池流量差别是非常非常大所以当下的整个拼头都你们会发现一个很奇怪的现象你去搜索
我去搜索任何一款产品的时候比如说我去搜索一个实验金你会发现拥有黑标的白补贴的秒杀的会优先在前面去进行展现展现的原因是什么呢是因为黑标店铺拥有天然的倾斜所以在店铺类型的时候建议大家去做商标品牌的时间店专卖店专营店因为它的整个的权重和以前已经完全不一样了拼头都以前可能没有太多的权重店铺权重的
区分最近这段时间的变化非常非常的大最后呢在营销活动上面会有哪些区别呢就是参加营销活动时同等条件下企业店会更有优势会优先被考虑黑标店铺有专属的营销活动比如说白衣补贴牛量更大直动车更好开啊同时呢白衣补贴的又分成商家自行补贴和官方补贴大多数的白衣补贴现在都是商家自补官补需要特定条件和
特定的一个产品 这个东西你得具体去咨询品牌小二 这个地方给大家去强调一个东西 如果说你在拼多多里面一天已经能做到一万块钱 两万块钱 三万块钱 以上的这种类型的商家
甭管你有多少个店 三个店 五个店 还是十个店 只要你做到一万两万块钱左右的销售额 你就应该去考虑把你自主的品牌变成能在拼多多里面上百亿补贴的黑标
我们公司就有这样的服务 并且2026年我们会拿出很多的案例 就是我们手上现在已经做了将近二十多个案例出来了 因为现在可能很多人都不知道哦 原来还能这么快速的去把自主品牌打成黑标上百亿 其实2026年会是整个拼多多品牌的元年 同时呢 也是你们在当下的三到五年左右的一个时间里面 拿住拼多多百亿补贴黑标最好的一个时机
那么这一节课程呢 跟大家去讲到这里 如果你们想要把自主品牌变成黑标 联系我们的班主任 就OK了 那么这一节课程呢 就讲到这里 我是[来源标识已去除] 祝大家天天报单